hey this is um another one of those
we predicted it but then when you read
about it
it's like even worse than what you
imagined
we have now learned that employees at
donald trump's chicago trump tower
were all vaccinated early well before
they were eligible
and interestingly this may not be about
trump specifically
but it probably is we're not completely
sure yet and you'll understand why in a
moment
the vaccination at this trump building
was arranged by a hospital co
that lives in the building and that's 37
year old anosh
ahmed 72 employees of trump's hotel and
condo tower
received vaccines on march 10 and 11
but city guidelines say that hotel
employees aren't actually
eligible for vaccination until march
29th so they were
almost three weeks early the mayor lori
lightfoot said quote
we have a finite amount of vaccine in
the city we've been really really
careful to make sure
we're using it in a way that prioritizes
the most vulnerable people who are most
at risk and most at risk of
spreading it adding we can't have
something like this happen again
now the hospital itself is located
in a mostly black neighborhood nine
miles from trump tower
it claims that its mission is to provide
vaccines to the quote
minority communities hardest hit
by the coronavirus pandemic but what
happened
is vaccines were taken from there and
brought nine miles
to trump tower it's sort of the epitome
of the worst
of the worst now is it just coincidence
that
it's trump tower what i mean by that is
okay the co
a nosh ahmed lives in the tower and
uh maybe it was just what he would have
done
regardless of where he lived and it has
nothing whatsoever to do with the trump
family except
that anosha ahmed bragged
that eric trump was one of the
individuals vaccinated
and there's even a picture of them
together although it's not immediately
clear if this picture is
from vaccination day that we are
currently showing the audience
ahmed also sent to others a picture of
himself
posing with eric trump on march 13th
eric trump tweeted two pictures of the
chicago tower and the city skyline which
confirms that
he was in chicago right around the days
when this vaccination
at trump tower was supposedly taking
place
so it's not looking particularly good
the hospital initially said oh we were
confused
we thought that hotel employees were
already eligible but then we found out
that they weren't really
eligible that seems insanely difficult
to believe
if you're gonna drive the vaccines from
the hospital to trump tower
and you don't even know whether you're
not even going to really check whether
the hospital workers are eligible
they said they thought that the hospital
were the hotel workers rather were
eligible so
that imploded so their newest statement
um is that well listen even if they
weren't yet eligible
a lot of those 72 vaccinated trump
employees
were black and brown which is just sort
of like now you're gonna pull the race
card yourselves as the story crumbles
so it all stinks this is just one story
and there are hundreds or thousands of
stories
just like it most don't involve trump by
the way
read up on what's happening in argentina
where i was born
with vaccinations anything you can
imagine is happening there
functionaries of the government are
being caught with
literally thousands of vaccine doses in
the trunks of their cars
when they're asked what are you doing
with that they're saying oh i was
transporting them
you're transporting vaccines that
doesn't really make any sense the
governor
of the province of buenos aires so
buenos ai it's almost like new
york city and state you have buenos
aires the city
and you have buenos aires the province
the governor of the province of buenos
aires
has been involved in under the table
vaccinations for prominent people they
even there's
there's like a prominent argentinian
authors and intellectuals
who reported they were offered vaccines
even though they don't qualify
uh they live in the province i mean this
stuff is rampant globally
it was only a matter of time until one
of these vaccination scandals touched
the trump family and this is the first
one we know of
uh taking place in chicago so we'll see
what else we can learn about it
one week from today friday march 26th
very special day we start
spring break for the david pakman show
no but in all seriousness
we're doing a one-day membership special
february the first part of march
it's not been great from the standpoint
of memberships a lot of people writing
saying david i've got to cancel i just
can't afford it i'm cutting this i'm
cutting hbo
i'm cutting cable uh and i get it so we
are doing a huge one day membership
special
friday march 26th if you want to
hear about it on the day of with
instructions about how to sign up
get on my newsletter at davidpakman.com
and friday morning you'll get an email
telling you exactly how to sign up
we'll take a quick break we will hear
from you i want to hear
what is on your mind we will take some
calls via discord momentarily
and much more coming up today if you are
anything like me
you probably aren't thrilled with the
idea of going into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a practical
and affordable way to take control of
your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you
up with an in-person provider to do
things like blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
co-pays
there are so many practical advantages
to using steady md for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video